the other debate was this Gretchen
Whitmer she is the governor of Michigan
and she is going against Republican
Tudor Dixon and if you want to just see
a liar in action like an incredible
extraordinary liar and they only do it
because they can get away with it here's
Gretchen Whitmer Governor you've been in
office for four years now Harry Truman
said the buck stops at your desk you've
had four years to try to fix education
in this state why is it not where you
would want it to go at least four years
ago where you said you wanted to go
we've also had some historic challenges
over the last few years I think to put
it lately you know Mrs Dixon says that I
kept students out longer than any other
state that's just not true I worked
closely with my Republican and
Democratic governor so kids were out for
three months lie lie you liar and we all
know it Michigan had some of the most
Draconian lockdowns there are a million
articles how kids were out for well more
than that how when schools wanted to
reopen she worked with the the teachers
unions to keep the kids out she also
this is the same woman that literally
did not want people gardening she she
banned the sale of plants and vegetables
that we we saw plenty of images of it I
actually sent I went shopping in Crazy
dystopia in Los Angeles I went to my
Home Depot and I bought a bunch of seeds
and I sent them to fans in Michigan she
is a liar and a terrible human being
but fortunately there was another person
on that stage Republican Tudor Dixon and
she was not having it I'm pretty sure I
just heard an audible gasp around town
when Gretchen Whitmer said that kids
were out of school for three months
perhaps she wasn't paying attention to
what was actually happening even we even
had schools that were closed this year
this is shocking to me that she thinks
that schools were only closed for three
months or maybe she thinks she can
convince you that schools were only
closed for three months but you know
better because your students are the
ones that are desperately behind and the
test scores show that she's being
dishonest about this she's being
dishonest about even trying to get into
these schools to get these schools back
on track yeah that's good that's clear
that's honest that's great it's exactly
what I always say you tell the truth you
say it clearly but the thing is Whitmer
knows she can say outright lies like
that because of again media running
cover for Democrats so she has the balls
to get up there the the moderator should
have been like what the f are you
talking about lady this past year not
2020. this past year we were still
closing down some schools here
okay so be it uh Tudor Dixon who I did
not know a tremendous amount about
before this debate uh she went after the
debate she got all the media around her
like there were like 20 reporters right
in her face and she just plowed through
question after question after question
after question and did an absolutely
great job the the Democrats obviously
are never subjected to that sort of uh
situation uh here's about 30 seconds of
it can you maybe talk about that you
know what would have to go wrong I guess
for you not to accept results made it
clear that if she runs an illegal
election again that would be a problem
I'm hoping that she won't do that
tutor you Jonathan knows thing George
Michigan um you claim the governor
forced people to get vaccines can you
clarify that comment Michigan never had
amended um I was talking about her vax
to normal program that said if we wanted
to have our freedoms and Liberties back
then we had to get to a certain
percentage of people that were vaxed
consider Zach Workshop from Dogwood
service you've been critical of schools
remaining closed but as Governor what
would you have done for school districts
their school boards decided we are going
to remain in a virtual posture instead
of going to in person what could you
imagine what would you have done we saw
other states like Florida that said we
are going to have schools in person that
that's critical and that's what we
should have done in the state of
Michigan we saw schools we saw other
states opening their schools and the
children were safe and they ended up
having much less learning loss than the
state of Michigan all right that's a
small portion of it she just went on and
on and on tried a picture can you even
picture a Democrat getting that kind of
scrutiny just question question question